- Do you want to evaluate
the definite integral
from three to three, of F of X, D X.
And we're given the graph of F of X,
and of Y equals F of X,
and the area between F of X,
and the X-axis over different intervals.
Well when you look at this,
you actually don't even have to look
at this graph over here,
because in general, if I
have the definite integral
of any function F of X, D X,
from let's say, A to the same value,
from one value to the same value,
this is always going to be equal to zero.
We're going from three to three.
We could be going from
negative pi to negative pi.
It's always going to be zero.
One way to think about it,
we're starting and stopping here at three,
so we're not capturing any area.
Let's do another one.
So here, we want to find
the definite integral
from seven to four, of F of X, D X.
So we want to go from seven to four.
Now you might be tempted to say,
okay well look, the area
between F of X and X, is two,
so maybe this thing is two.
But the key realization
is, this area only applies
when you have the lower
bound as the lower bound,
and the higher value as the higher bound.
So the integral from four to seven
of F of X, D X, this thing.
This thing is equal to two.
This thing is depicting
that area right over there.
So what about this,
where we've switched it?
Instead of going from four to seven,
we're going from seven to four.
Well the key realization is,
is if you switch the bounds,
this is a key definite integral property,
that's going to give
you the negative value.
So this is going to be equal
to the negative of the integral
from four to seven, of F of X, D X.
And so this is going to be negative,
and we just figured out the
integral from four to seven
of F of X, D X, well
now that is this area.
F of X is above the X-axis.
It's a positive area.
So it is going to be,
so this thing right over
here is going to evaluate
to positive two, but we have
that negative out front,
so our original expression
would evaluate to negative two.